we've got an O for that confirmed what's
in a way we've got exactly 10 minutes to
decide if you really want to know hey
youtubers it's Charlie and I just posted
my review of the first episode of agents
of shield so now I want to talk about
episodes 2 & 3 we've got some details
about what's going to be happening and
some of the characters we're going to be
meeting as well as what's looking like
the first super villain of the season
they already have a promo for episode 2
it's called zero eight four and that's
basically like a shield code reference
like place code like 187 for alien
object so what it looks like is
something from say like Thor's armory
like the tesseract or the Cosmic Cube
obviously I don't think it's that I
think it's just a stray alien object of
great power that's something as great as
say the tesseract otherwise why wouldn't
the Avengers be there but during the
episode we're gonna be a lot of cool
Coulson backstory from this character
called commandant Camilla riah's it
turns out she was either a girlfriend or
a former coworker so I think that she's
gonna have some amazing Coulson stories
that she'll be telling the other team
members in this episode so episode 3 is
actually the big episode that I'm really
looking forward to we're gonna meet a
character called dr. Franklin Hall the
team is basically it's called the asset
and this Franklin Hall character is the
asset so they basically had to rush in
to rescue him after he gets kidnapped
but the interesting thing is that in the
Marvel Universe this character is
actually the super villain graviton
obviously during this episode based on
the description it kind of makes it
sound like he's going to turn into
graviton so he might reappear throughout
the series I don't know if he'll be the
big bad but I think they're kind of
setting it up that way they also might
use his character to tie into some of
this project centipede that they talked
about in the first episode if you
remember the tick on J August Richards
arm his procedures were basically a
combination of extremists and Chitauri
tech so I'm guessing that dr. Hall is
actually has something to do with this
too it is important to note though that
the character does not start out as a
super villain so I think when they meet
him in this episode he'll just be a
normal scientist working on super-secret
government projects that's totally
normal right there are some other
characters that they're going to have in
that episode too but they're not part of
the Marvel Canon so I think there's
going to be one off characters or
original characters that they're just
going to loosely tie in
but I'm really excited about that main
villain so hopefully he will turn out to
be the main villain
speaking of big characters on the show a
lot of people like Samuel al Jackson Tom
Hiddleston and Sam Rockwell have talked
about really wanting to appear on the
show at least in cameos so I expect
samuel l.jackson would probably the
first of that bunch just because he's
Nick Fury he's director of shield
obviously they're probably going to try
and work him in and some brief cameos it
looks throughout the season if not the
season finale and obviously Tom
Hiddleston is not gonna be in any Marvel
movies after Thor 2 for a while so I
think they're really gonna try and work
him into at least in reference if they
can especially since the Thor movie is
coming up so they just kind of want to
dovetail on the popularity and the
marketing that they're doing around that
movie I have not mentioned Cobie
Smulders though remember she's in the
final season of How I Met Your Mother
obviously they're already done shooting
that so she's moving on to other things
now so she's gonna pop up throughout
this season and she's not gonna be a
series regular I mean she's not gonna be
featured in all the big scenes but
whenever their shield headquarters I
would expect to see her and up to the
top now Joss Whedon has actually been
working overtime on a lot of these first
couple of episodes Marvel kind of
airlifts him in to fix scripts whenever
things are in trouble he actually went
to the Thor set and helped alan taylor
fix the thor movie while they were
shooting it that's literally how much in
demand he is in the Marvel Universe
right now so he is their most precious
asset but it's totally normal for them
to do a lot of rewrites especially page
one rewrites when a show is brand new so
I'm not surprised that Joss Whedon has
been rewriting a lot of the shield
scripts either so a lot of people said
that might be a bad thing but I don't
think it's a bad thing at all I totally
trust Brigette Antron and Jed Whedon so
it's gonna be a great show but based on
a lot of this information we have about
the next couple of episodes what kind of
alien tech are they going to be running
into and what is this new villain going
to be is he going to be the big villain
is he going to turn into graviton
remember they said they're not going to
include too many characters from the
Marvel movie universe but I'm interested
to see how many C and D level villains
end up popping up on the show over
season 1 like I said I'll be doing
agents of shield videos every Tuesday
night be sure to subscribe to get them
I'll try and post them as soon as
possible up to the broadcast but a lot
of times when I do two videos like I did
tonight it just takes me a little bit
longer to get them out thank you so much
for watching in the meantime you can
actually watch my review that first
episode here and you can watch all my
other Marvel videos by clicking here
they
you so much you guys are amazing see you
tomorrow high fives